- [Instructor] In this
video, we're going to build
on our understanding of Mendelian genetics
and Punnett squares
by starting to think
about two different genes.
So we're going back to the pea plant,
and we're gonna think about
the gene for pea color
and the gene for pea shape.
So let's say that in
the parental generation,
you have one parent that
is homozygous dominant
for both of these genes.
So their genotype is capital Y, capital Y,
and capital R, capital R.
So their phenotype for sure
is going to be yellow round,
and we also see the genotype.
We see which alleles it has.
Now, let's say that that is crossed
with the homozygous recessive parent.
So in this case, it's going
to be green-colored peas.
It's counterintuitive
to write green with a y,
a lowercase y in the color yellow,
but the lowercase y represents green.
And also these are wrinkled green peas.
So I will write that with
the lowercase r here.
And so the phenotype here is going
to be green and wrinkled for sure.
Now, what's going to
happen when they cross?
What does the F1 generation look like?
Well, we know from
Mendel's law of segregation
for each of these genes, that
when a gamete is created,
it randomly gets one copy
of each of these genes.
So for this first one,
it's going to randomly get
one of these capital Ys.
So it's going to get a capital Y for sure
from this first parent.
And it's also going to randomly
get one of these capital Rs.
So it's going to get a capital R for sure
from that first parent.
And then by the same logic,
it's going to randomly get one
of these two lowercase y's.
So it's going to get a
lowercase y for sure,
and it's going to randomly get one
of these two lowercase r's,
so it's going to get a
lowercase r for sure.
So this is the genotype for
all of the F1 generation.
This is often known as a dihybrid.
It is heterozygous in both genes.
Now, what's the phenotype here?
Well, we know yellow is dominant,
and we know round is dominant.
So if we looked at these
plants right over here,
their peas would still be yellow round,
just like this homozygous
parent over here.
Now, what's interesting is when you do
what's known as a dihybrid cross
when you cross one of this F1 generation
with itself or with each other.
And to do that,
I'm gonna create a four by
four Punnett square here.
And so one parent here
is going to be hybrid in
or heterozygous in the color gene
and also heterozygous in the shape gene.
And that's going to be true
of the other parent as well.
Heterozygous or hybrid in the color gene
and also heterozygous in the shape gene.
And so that's why this is
called a dihybrid cross.
You're crossing things
that are hybrid in two different genes.
Now, we've already talked
about the law of segregation.
The gamete is randomly going
to get one copy of each gene.
Now, Mendel also has the law
of independent assortment,
which tells us the alleles
of different genes
segregate independently.
So for this parent here,
whether it contributes a
capital Y or a lowercase y
is independent of whether
it contribute a capital R
or a lowercase r.
Now, there is a little bit of a asterisk,
a little caveat on there.
We now know that genes sit on chromosomes.
One chromosome will have many genes on it.
And this law of independent
assortment only applies
to genes that are actually
sitting on different chromosomes.
If they sit on the same chromosome,
they generally are not going
to assort independently.
But let's just assume the
law of independent assortment
'cause this is true for most genes.
So this first parent can
contribute a capital Y
out of this first gene
and a capital R out of the second gene,
or they could contribute
the lowercase copy
of the first gene
and the capital R copy of the second gene,
this capital R, the round
allele of the second gene.
And we could go through
every combination here.
It could also contribute the yellow allele
and the wrinkled allele.
Or it could contribute the green allele
and the wrinkled allele as well.
And the same would be true
for this other dihybrid,
this other parent right over here.
So let me just write that down.
They could contribute capital
Y in two of the scenarios.
They could contribute a lowercase y
or the green allele in
two of the scenarios.
And they could contribute a capital R
in two of the scenarios, a round allele,
or a lowercase r in two of the scenarios,
a wrinkled allele.
So you have all of the
different combinations
that each of them can contribute.
Once again, whether you get the yellow
or the green is independent
of whether you get the
round or the wrinkled.
So these are all equally
probably right over here.
When the two gametes from
these two parents merge,
we can then look at what the genotype
of the offspring is going to be,
really the genotype of the F2 generation
'cause we're crossing two
members of the F1 generation.
So I encourage you to pause this video
and fill in this grid.
See if you can figure
the different genotypes
that will result.
All right, now let's do this together.
So this scenario right over here,
you're getting a capital
Y from both parents,
and you're getting a
capital R from both parents.
This scenario over here,
you're getting a capital
Y from this parent,
lowercase y from that parent,
and then you're getting
a capital R from both.
This scenario over here,
capital Y from both parents.
Capital Y, capital Y.
And you're getting a
capital R from this parent
and a lowercase r from that parent.
And then this scenario over here,
you're getting gonna capital
Y allele from this parent
and lowercase y from that parent,
and you're getting a
capital R from this parent
and a lowercase r from that parent.
And now I'm just going
to speed up the video
and just fill in the rest of
these using the same logic.
All right, now that we've
filled out this Punnett square,
let's think about the
different phenotypes.
How many of these plants are going
to produce yellow round peas?
Pause the video and think about it.
Well, it's yellow and round.
It has to have at least one
capital Y and one capital R.
So that one's going to
be yellow and round.
This is going to be yellow and round.
That's yellow and round as well.
This is yellow and round.
That's yellow and round.
And that one is yellow and round.
And then last but not least,
I think this is the last one
that is both yellow and round.
And actually let me make
a little color code here.
Yellow plus round.
And here we're talking
about the phenotype.
You can see we have
different genotypes here,
but because both yellow
and round are dominant,
as long as you have at
least one Y and one R,
you're going to have a yellow
plus round phenotype over here.
So you have one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine.
And I will say there's
nine of these over here.
Now, how many of these are going
to be yellow plus wrinkled?
Pause the video and think
about that, that phenotype.
So yellow and wrinkled,
you're going to have to have a capital Y
and two lowercase r's
in order to be wrinkled.
So you have at least one
capital Y and two lowercase r's,
and least one capital Y
and two lowercase r's.
Let's see, at least one capital
Y and two lowercase r's.
It looks like you have
exactly three of them,
that phenotype.
And then what about the other way around?
What if we are looking for,
I'll do it in this green color,
green plus round?
How many of them exhibit that phenotype?
Well, to be green and round,
you have to have two lowercase y's,
and you have to have
at least one capital R.
So this would be green and round.
This would be green and round.
And then this would be
green and round as well.
So you have three of those.
And then how many of them are going
to be both green and wrinkled?
Well, I think you see that
one scenario over here
that is both green and wrinkled,
having that homozygous
recessive phenotype.
And so if you were to do this many times,
you'd expect the ratios between
these various phenotypes
to be nine to three to three to one.
And when Mendel and many other people
since Mendel have done
these types of experiments,
they have seen that statistically,
this is what you see
in that F2 generation.
Now, you're unlikely to get exactly a nine
to three to three to one ratio.
It's all probabilistic.
Every one of these 16
scenarios are equally likely,
so you would expect this nine to three
to three to one ratio,
but you're not always going
to get that exact ratio.
You'll probably get something close to it.